right so today we're going to talk about
one of the great unsolved problems in
mathematics that went back to the
ancient greeks
thousands of years ago which was
eventually
solved in
1882 and it's the problem is called
squaring the circle and you may have
even heard of the problem as a metaphor
for something that's impossible to do
the question is can you make a square
with the same area as a circle
now you have to understand the rules in
ancient greece they didn't have algebra
so they could only construct numbers
using lines and circles so you could
only make things using a straight edge
like a ruler but not a measured ruler
there's a straight edge and a compass so
lines and circles those are the rules
those are the rules that the ancient
greeks had to work by
using those rules
can you
construct a square with the same area as
a circle let's have a look at what you
can do with rules and compasses
you can add numbers here's a line and it
has length a then i add another line of
length b and the whole thing
is a plus b
so you can add numbers together quite
easily with lines you can subtract
numbers as well if i start with b
and then i mark off a length which i'm
going to call a then this bit here
that's going to be b minus a we can
multiply if i draw a little triangle
here let's do like that
this has length 1
and this has length a
i'm going to scale up the triangle
like this if i scale it up so now that
this has a length b the big triangle has
length b
then this has been scaled up as well so
this has a length a times b you can
divide same idea but it's kind of the
reverse of that i took a bigger triangle
if that had a length of b
and the
long edge here has a length of a and if
i scale it down so now this has a length
of one
then this has been scaled down as well
and you scale it down so it has a length
of a divided by b
so you can divide by scaling triangles
as well
and there's one more thing you can do if
i draw a line here this is a
i'm going to add 1 to it
that's 1
and then i'm going to draw a semi-circle
and this length
here
is the square root
of a
and that's all you can do that is it
with us with a ruler and a compass you
can add multiply divide subtract
work out square roots and that is it
that is all you can do the numbers you
make using those rules are called
constructable numbers so all those
numbers are just repeated use of those
few rules if we had a circle if we had a
circle let's make this easy let's say
this circle has a radius of one
the area
of the circle
is pi
times the radius squared and the radius
is squared well that's one
so the area of the circle is just pi
so i want a square with the same area i
want a square now that has an area of pi
and you may be ahead of me here because
if a square has an area of pi the
lengths of the sides
are the square root of pi
now it's the square root of pi now we
can do square roots that's allowed
so there's nothing yet to say that we
can't do this
so what's the problem well we know that
pi is irrational
actually that wasn't easy to work out we
only worked that out quite recently by
quite recently i mean 1761 but being
irrational is not enough there are
constructable numbers
that are irrational
you can make the square root of two
quite easily
and you can make the square root of the
square root of 2 and and so on so being
irrational is not enough
to say that this can't be done if i'm
allowed to make this a bit more general
if i'm allowed to use other sort of
roots like cube roots or fifth roots or
nth roots if i'm allowed to add those in
as well then numbers that you can make
using those rules are called algebraic
numbers that's just a bit more general
same idea
and it turned out that they were able to
prove that pi
was not an algebraic number and if it's
not an algebraic number then it's
definitely
not a constructable number now this is
what i like the word for a number that
is not algebraic is called a
transcendental number which is a
fantastic word now to prove something is
transcendental it's really hard
in fact mathematicians had
shown that transcendental numbers
existed
seven years before they had even found
an example of a transcendental number so
you have to imagine in those seven years
people were saying to the mathematicians
all right so show me a transcendental
number come on show me a transcendental
number but it was a really hard thing to
do eventually they were found they found
a few examples of this
but we still had to wait
until we were able to prove that pi
itself
was transcendental and then that was
done
in
once we've shown that
we've shown that pi is not constructable
and that is a proof
that you cannot square the circle can
you only not square the circle given the
parameters of these rules in this game
could a computer square a circle yeah so
you can you can make a square with sides
that have length root
pi
so absolutely so in terms so to the
modern day people with our tools of
algebra
right
algebra is fantastic so people complain
about algebra and having to learn
algebra at school but if we didn't have
algebra we would be doing maths like the
ancient greeks did maths
i promise you that would be much much
worse your textbooks would be ridiculous
and they'll be very wordy
algebra is an amazing powerful tool in
mathematics it's not there to cause you
problems it's there for a reason it's
brilliant so we it's this is easy to
make a square
with
the area of pi
but using the greek rules
straight lines and circles
it's impossible to do
you say it's easy to make a square with
the area pi
but because pi has this nature where the
digits sort of continue and we can't
even get to the exact figure
surely you can't make a square that's
exactly pi because you don't even know
what pie is or you can do it can you
you can do it and you're you're treading
on
something called zeno's paradox there
which we're about to do next
okay
so
for a second video in a row we're going
to tell people they have to wait to find
out more
if that's the way you want to play it
brady it is your choice this is brady's
decision right he's stringing you along
here
the the representatives uh actually
passed it unanimously 67 to zero they
passed it now this is the weird bit
on the same day that they were passing
the bill